no we're security guard I'm not gonna be
your stupid announcer you could get in
trouble for this fine I'll be my own
announcer again I need you I'm better
off this way
welcome to the gate show from sunshine
studios today Fred Willard food delivery
mistakes lindblum Hollywood buddies
Basma supper and now a man will never
date a girl with a dragon tattoo
Fred Stoller all right when I did this
weekend on Walt
Marn I joined the gym they told me not
to work out in the window it'll hurt
business cuz I'm skinny and it's some
new though I'm new all right let's go to
the cleavage hand cleavage panel do we
have a hole he looked like some models
driving in that could be Halle Berry and
that's someone's sex in the city to
menopause can be cruel what the hell
were you
I got a great idea to get the guests in
a better mood okay before the interview
we put them in a green room and we get
them all liquored up so they get loose
we're gonna do that
I got us one bro wait you got us a
greenroom sure did you did if you did
that's a good thing finally good idea
but it was mine no I don't don't you
ever did I come up with that one
hi I'm Fred Willard I'm here to do the
talk show I said to come in gate 33
ladies and gentlemen Fred Willard hey
you know what we should do before the
interview why don't I take Fred into the
greenroom get them loosened up right
yeah you got a valet part of their car
oh oh yeah that way sure why do you want
but I want a very casual or I brought a
suit there
be careful Scarborough's electronic keys
oh yeah that'll be the green room that
was the best idea I ever had Fred
Willard will be 10 felt so much better
interview once he's in the green room
it'll be looser and crazy at craziest
stories this way Freddy was the green
room Oh be careful with that car I had
some ideas of different ways to go I
just had some porno magazines and a beer
to get you started I get to loose loose
well I'm kind of loose already
I just want to see a segment producer so
are you on the show I just gonna film
with Morgan Freeman I'd rather let you
talk about it because it's not out for a
couple more you'll be a free man soon
enough what time is the show stars are
terrible yeah that's what I call loose I
can make all your wishes come true
all my wishes all of them let me think
oh I've got one hey is that Charlie
Sheen keep the car now Oscar will
present this segment celebrities at the
commissary where is he he's relaxing
getting loose in the greenroom
in the green room back it up back it up
back it up it's great about me as I'm
young I'm I'm the voice in the face of
youth I'm youngest talk-show host except
for Conan Jimmy Kimmel Jimmy Fallon yeah
you're younger than Letterman those
vitamins yeah I don't know about Leno I
think you might be the same age oh well
he has like sort of young face like a
baby face your face look doesn't think
it's a good about talk to us we can do
this forever right
right nobody's kicking me out of my
booth I'm a franchise that's right
you